10 en cours mais plus largement c'est
l'occasion de critiques vie sur une
agriculture intensive et la recherche
d'une productivité maximum un choix qui
n'est pas récent mais les moyens
utilisés pour obtenir des rendements de
plus en plus importants ont certainement
conduit à l' usage de produits dangereux
pour la santé
enquête et rythmique chaque année la
france produit 2 millions de tonnes de
porc autant de viande de boeuf un
million et demi de tonnes de fromages
des wagons de blé et de légumes la
france est le premier exportateur
mondial de produits agroalimentaires cet
essor prodigieux a démarré il y a près
de 40 ans à l'époque de gaulle et
pompidou vous laissant agir la
paysannerie française de son retard
l'europe se construisait aussi un accord
est passé aux allemands les machines
outils aux français l'agriculture
l'autosuffisance et l'objectif
prioritaire
mais très vite la conquête des marchés
européens s'organisent l'agriculture
devient un moderne performante mécanisée
l'emploi massif des engrais des
pesticides augmenté revenu à la fin des
années 60 les pouvoirs publics
choisissent d'encourager la grande
distribution
car pour juguler l'inflation il faut des
prix les plus bas possibles
l'arrivée des supermarchés accentue le
productivisme l'élevage bascule dans un
autre univers
les volailles sont élevées en batterie
un tiers des veaux ne grandissent plus
sous la mer mais sont plutôt gavés aux
médicaments et aux hormones c'est quand
même des mots qui viennent d'eux sous la
manière qu'ont mais comme vous voyez en
chef dans le chacal il faut qu'ils
s'adaptent et ça va pas tout seul durant
ces trente glorieuses le monde rural
perdre à 75 pour cent de sa
main-d'oeuvre l'effort d'adaptation est
énorme
les agriculteurs ils ont fait les
efforts considérables de productivité
cette productivité a été en grande
partie confisqué par la filière pour
faire profiter le consommateur de bas
prix et c'est pratiquement la grande
distribution qui a mené le bal depuis
ces dernières années en faisant pression
sur l'industrie agroalimentaire qui elle
même a fait un peu pression sur les
coulter en 1996 ce système ultra
productiviste dérape la crise de la
vache folle va réveiller tout le monde
des contrôles draconiens sont alors mis
en place consciente de la nouvelle
attente du consommateur la grande
distribution redore son image en vantant
les mérites de l'agriculture bio mais
est il possible de revenir à des modes
de production moins intensifs
si l'on veut continuer à exporter